Speaker 1: Today I report to you
may be the most extreme salvo
in the Republican Civil War that we have seen
so far. Mitch McConnell abandoning the line from
the Republican National Committee and referring to
the Trump riots as a violent insurrection. So far,
no response from Donald Trump. But Donald
Trump for months now has been going after
Mitch McConnell attacking Senate Minority Leader
former Majority Leader Mitch McConnell for not
doing this enough and not doing that enough and
not being grateful enough that Trump helped them
get reelected and all these different things.
And Mitch McConnell has now come out and said
January 6th was a violent insurrection, very
different language than we've seen from the RNC.
As the Hill reports, Senate Minority Leader Mitch
McConnell criticized the RNC for its censure of
Congress people. Adam Kinzinger and Liz Cheney
and broke with their language on the Trump riots,
calling it a violent insurrection. Violent
insurrection. Let's take a look at the video
here. Is Mitch McConnell asked about it and in
no uncertain terms, uses language that is not
going to be pleasant for Trump or the RNC,
Speaker 2: censor two sitting members of
Congress and also use the words
legitimate political discourse in
Speaker 4: talking about Jan. six. Well, let me
give you my view of what happened January the 6th
and we're all. We're here, we're here. We
saw it happen. It was a violent insurrection
for the purpose of trying to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power after a legitimately certified
election from one administration to the next.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt, who can possibly say
that what Mitch McConnell is saying is wrong?
But Mitch McConnell is no hero, right? I mean,
Mitch McConnell declined to hold Trump accountable
in the immediate aftermath of the event. You guys
remember this. I know it sort of feels like it was
a long time ago, and yet it feels very recent. But
remember that when the second Trump impeachment
happened, remember, Trump is a twice impeached
former president when the second impeachment
of Donald Trump happened. Mitch McConnell said,
Listen, Trump was responsible. This was what it
was, it was terrible. But impeachment is a limited
tool, and Trump is not constitutionally eligible
for impeachment conviction. He had the biggest
cop out at the time where he said, Well, yeah,
he did it. He did the thing that we're accusing
him of doing. But impeachment can only be used
in very narrow circumstances, and this is not
one of those circumstances. And so I must vote
against conviction in the second impeachment of
Donald Trump. McConnell is pathetic. He chose to
protect the Republican Party instead of doing what
was right for the country at the time. And now he
says, Well, yeah, it was a violent insurrection.
So much like when George W. Bush drunkenly
stumbled, I shouldn't say drunkenly. I know he
used to have an alcohol problem. I
meant metaphorically drunkenly stumbles
when George W. Bush inadvertently stumbles across
the correct take on something related to Trump.
We don't say why. What a good guy, huh? No, it's
still war criminal George W. Bush. It's still the
same George W. Bush that got us into two wars and
one on completely fabricated intelligence. I mean,
it's still George W. Bush. And in the same way,
we're interested in Mitch McConnell directly
saying it's a violent insurrection. It was a
violent insurrection. We're interested in it
because it's completely at odds with Donald Trump.
It is a at odds with what the Republican National
Committee decided at the recent meeting and,
you know, at odds with what they did with the
Congressman Kinzinger and Congresswoman Liz
Cheney. And we're interested in it because it
is fomenting this civil war, which hopefully
will be destructive to the Republican Party
in the midterms that are now just
barely eight and a half months away.
But it's not because we like Mitch McConnell. The
guy is pathetic, and we shouldn't forget that.